let's go to the phones by which i mean
the discord lines as we often do
on fridays you can find the david pakman
show discord at davidpakman.com
slash discord get into the waiting lobby
if you would like to talk to me let's
start today with dylan from kentucky
dylan you're on the air what's going on
hey david can you hear me yes i can hey
yeah i wanted to
specifically uh talk a little bit about
the vaccine and some of the rhetoric
around um what we can do after we get it
so i know that we've
that you've talked a little bit about
being able to gather if everyone is
vaccinated right but but what
what is the difference between saying
hey we can have small gatherings
of people who are all vaccinated and say
you know a large gathering of everyone
that is vaccinated because isn't that
you know localized herd immunity i think
we need to be more optimistic
about the vaccine yeah i mean i think
that
your point isn't a crazy one which is
with vaccines that are
65 to 95 effective
if you have all vaccinated people in a
room whether it's
four people six people or 20 people
the odds of having both a vaccinated
person
that somehow got it and then them giving
it
to another vaccinated person who somehow
will get it obviously you're talking
about low percentages here but i do
think it makes sense to go in steps
and the the other thing is most states
right now have limits on the size of
gatherings anyway
uh sometimes it's 10 sometimes it's 20.
so
once you say that the number for the
size of gatherings is different for
vaccinated versus unvaccinated it starts
to get kind of complicated anyway so for
me
it it makes sense if you're vaccinated
get together in a small group and you
don't have to wear masks if you're at a
person's home
in many states there are still mask
mandates so if you're out
you you might be in a store or wherever
where you have to wear a mask anyway and
if there's going to be unvaccinated
people the unvaccinated people should
all be from one household
it all makes sense to me but i agree
with you that these vaccines are really
good
and what's safe for vaccinated people
probably is a bit beyond what the cdc
has said so far i don't disagree with
you there
okay yeah that's yeah i mean i guess you
know there's some
hesitancy still around the vaccine and i
even saw an article
yesterday about you know even once you
get the vaccine
nothing really changes yeah i think
that's bad i i've said i've done a bunch
of clips where i say if you're telling
people nothing changes why would people
get vaccinated i think it makes sense to
be clear and say
things do change it becomes very
unlikely you will get the disease
if you were to get it it becomes almost
a zero percent chance that you will get
it seriously
the israeli data is it reduces
transmission you can hang out and hug
and be without masks with vaccinated
people
you yeah i think it makes sense to be
very clear that
there's a lot that changes actually and
the more people that get it the more
quickly it will change
right right all right yeah that's that's
the main thing i wanted to bring up just
because i i feel like
there needs to be a higher amount of
optimism around yes and i don't see that
happening right now
i agree i think it's happening more and
the cdc guidelines were good and i think
soon we'll probably get
more more updates on those guidelines
but we need more more of the optimism
for sure these are game-changing
vaccines
right all right david i appreciate it
all right thank you great to hear from
you
uh always always love hearing from folks
from
all states from all states let's go next
to freddy from
tampa freddy from tampa you're on the
air
freddy from tampa please unmute you're
on the air hey
good afternoon david pakman how are you
i'm doing well thank you
i'm i don't have a political question i
wanted to ask you
what's your favorite movie oh i don't
have a single favorite but that's like
saying what's your favorite book you
know how
uh i i don't know i'm not a huge movie
guy
but i couldn't possibly tell my favorite
single movie i don't know
i mean uh you know the land before time
still gets me i've loved that one since
i was a kid but uh no i don't i don't
know
thank you so much uh i love your show
thanks all right my pleasure
sorry i don't have a you know some
people say what's your favorite book and
it's like
i don't know i you know i'm reading
three books every two weeks it's
it's really hard to say what if you
could read 10
books in just one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently checked out the
book podcast marketing strategy by
daniel rolls and
kieran rogers and so useful so
particularly applicable to what i'm
doing
really recommend it blinkist has books
on politics philosophy science they have
27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video